is there a border we will never cross
are there places we will never reach no
matter how hard we try
it turns out there are even with sci-fi
technology
we are trapped in a limited pocket of
the universe
and the finite stuff within it how much
universe
is there for us and how far can we go
if you look at the night sky you might
assume it will be there forever
stars are born and die again in a cycle
that feels
endless but it's not
take the milky way up to 200 000 light
years in diameter
containing some 100 to 400 billion stars
how many stars do you think are born
here each year
thousands millions the answer
is around three three new stars per year
95 of all the stars that will ever exist
in the universe have
already been born and we live at the
tail end of the age of star formation
we are at the beginning of the end of
the universe as we know it
the formation of new stars will continue
to slow down
but there's more it turns out that the
universe is
rushing away from us the milky way is
not alone
together with the andromeda galaxy and
more than 50 dwarf galaxies
it forms the local group a region of
space about
10 million light years in diameter our
galactic neighborhood
hundreds of galaxy groups like the local
group make up the laniakea supercluster
which itself is only one of a myriad of
superclusters
in total there are around two trillion
galaxies
that make up the current observable
universe
unfortunately even if we could travel at
light speed
around 94 percent of the galaxies we can
see
are already unreachable for us forever
let this number sink in for a moment
the simple fact that there's a limit for
us and that there is
so much universe that a human will never
be able to touch
is kind of frightening why are all of
these galaxies
out of reach already well it all has to
do with why there are galaxies in the
first place
the big bang we're simplifying here but
in a nutshell about 10 to the power of
minus 36 seconds after the big bang
the young universe was a very small
bubble of energy
it wasn't completely uniform though some
parts of it were a
tiny tiny bit denser than others which
had massive consequences
in a process called cosmic inflation the
observable universe expanded rapidly
from the size of a marble to trillions
of kilometers in a trillionth of a
second
that was so fast that all those tiny
differences in
density were stretched from subatomic
distances into
galactic distances which is why the
whole universe consists of
more and less dense regions pockets of
the universe
filled with a bit more stuff than the
space around them
after that short but powerful inflation
ended gravity began trying to pull
everything back together
inside the denser pockets gravity
emerged victorious and so over time
they grew into groups of galaxies like
the one we live in today
the local group is our pocket of the
universe
but at larger scales outside the denser
pocket
the expansion of space never stopped
this means that our local group is
surrounded by a lot of stuff
but none of those structures and
galaxies are gravitationally bound to us
the more the universe expands the larger
the distance between
us and the other gravitational pockets
becomes
even worse for us the expansion of the
universe is accelerating
we don't know why this happens so we
came up with the concept of dark energy
you can imagine it like an invisible
effect that speeds up the expansion of
the universe
we'll explain these concepts in more
detail in another video though
for now all you need to know is that the
universe is expanding
faster and faster this expansion means
that there's a cosmological horizon
around us
everything beyond it is traveling faster
relative to us
than the speed of light so everything
that passes the horizon
is irretrievably out of reach forever
and we will never be able to interact
with it again
in a sense it's like a black holes event
horizon
but all around us 94 of the galaxies we
can see today
have already passed it and are lost to
us forever
wait if we can't interact with them how
come we can still see them
well the way we're able to see something
is via light
and although the speed of light is the
fastest way to travel through the
universe
it needs time to get from one place to
another
every second light reaches us from
trillions of galaxies that have passed
the horizon
because when their light was emitted
they were much closer to us
we are looking at their ancient past and
see their ancient positions
so the observable universe is much
larger than the universe we can actually
interact with in a sense the universe is
pulling off a great show for us
showing us things that are out of reach
forever we have no idea what these
galaxies look like
today and we will never know but we will
be able to observe them for a long time
as their light hits our telescopes
interestingly this means that currently
the observable universe still appears to
be growing
as more and more light released by super
distant galaxies billions of years ago
is arriving at our doorsteps still
all the pockets of the universe outside
the local group
will one day pass our cosmological
horizon
once they do their light won't be able
to reach us anymore
and from our perspective they will fade
away
into darkness every second of your life
60 000 stars past the horizon
since you started watching this video
around 22 million stars have moved out
of our reach forever
okay but if 94 percent of the observable
universe is beyond the cosmic horizon
and gone forever that still leaves us
with six percent
that is technically in reach which is
still a ton of stuff
all the galaxy pockets that are less
than 18 billion light years away
they are still moving away but slow
enough that we could physically reach
them
although the chances are shrinking with
every second that passes
everything that's more than around 5
million light years away
is moving away from us but the closest
galaxy groups are receding the slowest
so there is a time window to jump galaxy
groups
the challenge is extreme though even for
type 3 civilizations
even at the speed of light a trip to the
mafi group the closest pocket of
galaxies outside the local group
would take 11 million years if some sort
of super motivated
super advanced civilization takes this
challenge on its potential sphere of
influence could expand to hundreds or
thousands of galaxies
although as time passes and the universe
grows
they would be separated forever it's
pretty safe to assume that humans will
not make this journey
at least not with technologies that are
even remotely on the horizon
for us the local group is most likely
the largest structure that we will ever
be a part of
just traveling between the stars would
be an achievement of
epic proportions we would already be
incredibly successful if we were to
colonize our cosmic backyard
which accounts for
zero 0.00000 zero zero zero one percent
of the observable universe as dark
energy pushes the rest of the universe
away from us
the local group will become more tightly
bound all its galaxies big and small
will merge together
to form one giant elliptical galaxy with
the unoriginal name
milk dromeda in a few billion years
this process might even smash huge gas
clouds together
and re-spark star formation for some
time
and this new light will be very welcome
because at some point
the galaxy's outside milk dromeda will
be so far away
that they become too faint to detect
once this happens
no information outside of the local
group will reach us
ever again the universe will recede from
view
a being born in the far future in
mildrometa will think that the universe
consists of nothing but its own galaxy
when they look far into empty space they
will only see
more emptiness and darkness they won't
see cosmic background radiation
and they won't be able to learn about
the big bang they may have no way of
knowing what we know today
the nature of the expanding universe
when it began and how it will end
they might think the universe is static
and eternal
milk dromeda will be an island in the
darkness slowly getting darker
and darker still with its trillion stars
the local group is certainly a big
enough playground to entertain humanity
for a while
after all we still haven't figured out
how to leave our solar system
and we have dozens of billions of years
at the very least
to explore our galaxy and we have the
incredible luck to exist at the perfect
moment in time
to see not only our future but also our
most
distant past just by looking into the
night sky
as isolated as the local group is it is
our home
and it really is a spectacular place
time for some behind the scenes content
you might have noticed that we sort of
already made this video a few years ago
but the original had a regrettable
mistake in it we said it would be
physically impossible to ever leave the
local group to reach
other galaxy groups but our travel limit
is actually much larger
as we showed in this video it's not
physically impossible to go further
but just extremely unlikely that it'll
ever happen
so why did we leave the video up well
it has to do with the nature of the
mistake we talked to astrophysicists
and they thought it didn't matter the
parts they considered important were
correct and they thought we should just
leave it and move on
so with that feedback we decided to
spare the video but since 2016
and ready thanks to you burbs we were
able to grow kotzeg and add
fact checkers to the team and develop an
in-depth process with experts and our
detailed sources documents to avoid
these sorts of mistakes
and also to make our work transparent we
can't avoid making mistakes from time to
time
but we can work hard on getting better
and this video kept bugging us
so we finally decided to replace it not
just re-upload
but remake it better and longer and add
fun universe facts to make it worthwhile
sorry for taking so long we'll leave the
old video up
but pin a comment and change the title
if you want to support us
and our sometimes exhausting but
hopefully worthwhile methods
you can watch share and click the bell
and get something from our shop
inspired by this video's topic we
created a milky way poster
and a local group poster and we're
working on a series about the entire
universe
visit our shop for more sciency and
kutzgazakti products
designed with love and produced with
care
in any case thank you for watching